[Musique]
dans quelques instants quelqu'un va pas
tarder à tirer ils veulent ce que vous
avez ils vont tous nous massacrer
jusqu'à ce qu'il est
[Musique]
mais quelqu'un on fait quoi on va pas
rester là toute la soirée c'est ton
anniversaire
j'ai 30 ans je bosse on chemise
hawaïenne et mon petit copain m'a largué
par six taureaux fait cramer ces
affaires on voudrait vous parlez de
brousse ailleurs c'est bien votre petite
amie drouet glacé
pardon il les croit
c était un espion c'est une longue
histoire je vais tout expliquer pourquoi
ils sont tous fous toi
il ya des scènes qui paverait mois et ne
cherche plus faucon et ce paquet à
vienne où des tas de gens vont mourir tu
veux mourir sans avoir vu l'europe où tu
veux aller en europe et mourir en ayant
vu l'europe
pourquoi est-ce que je n'ai que ces deux
options c'est vrai on millions
tout ça parce que tu te poses des
questions quand l'ouvragé
un groupe de terroristes projet toute
une série d'assassinats plein
d'innocents vont mourir si on ne
s'arrête pas et si on vous et paix
c'est surréaliste je dois reconnaître
que je suis
cela vient y tu es incroyable ils sont
sept
[Applaudissements]
m
pour reconnaître que vous êtes doué
c'est parce que je suis une vraie tueuse
au jeudi
c'est un truc de dingue tu t'es déjà
senti aussi libre et 7 pas mourir hockey
parce que je mourrais sans toit et du
coup on serait morts côté d'eux
[Musique]
lol
c'est pas vrai seigneur jésus c'est
râlant mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé
vous deux dans mon bureau quoi vous êtes
là big boss et vous n'avez pas sacrifier
nonce de féminité c'est la payons de ces
des services la bête noire de suie